yeah that's why i want to know what's
wrong with you now what are your traumas
there's a lot you get me and if i take
these shades off this whole room will
get dark
big man tenure is castillo first aka the
main event aka the sniper bath shout out
to your baby mother now big man senior
we live in a world full of clout chasers
bravo and i'm sick of it why can't a
real g let me find some real love brad
do you think i'm a couch chaser do i
look like a child chaser
yeah how this is gonna work is i'm
actually gonna slap money in front of
these galbraith 1000 for my eternal love
and i'm gonna try and find out if they
get them here for the money and clown or
they're there for real love big man
thing this is cloud chasers brad
my name is in alva
i'm a business operations lead for
community empowerment organization i'm
portuguese angolan
uh who else am i
i'm funny i'm smart i'm cheeky i'm the
nelva
i'm quite a strong woman and most of the
time i tend to dominate i know that
castillo has a bit of a powerful sort of
personality so see if it challenges me
challenge is good it's interesting spicy
and can you describe your perfect man
first and foremost it's in here he needs
to be emotionally mature or at least
willing to learn a little bit more about
the inside of his head to deal with
trauma with the bad things that happen
in life
tall
ideally
culturally aware
my must-have is he has to be
hard-working because that's the
beginning of everything you work hard
you'll be successful love is more
important than money
because you can get that from working
hard you can get that by luck winning
the lottery you know it's here today
it's gone tomorrow love is a bit more
powerful and substantial
do you think you can ever be with a
broke man i can as long as again like i
said you work hard working hard doesn't
mean you have to be rich it just means
that you're willing to put in you know
the effort that you need to put in to
complete the task you need to complete
at the best quality you can complete
them so if you work i don't mind you
work hard i'll be the smart one it's
fine am i here for love am i here for
money i'm here to see i mean if it's
impressive enough i'll be here for love
if not you know i'll take the money i'm
ready for that too i like new bags and
shoes so we'll see
hello nice to meet you nice to go okay
the handshake you know yeah keep
formalities first hey you look nice you
don't know get the chair for me oh my
bad my bad it's heavy
you look nice thank you so do you i like
your fur oh thank you i like that i like
the material that's definitely you know
feeling it in that it's silky cheese
that's nice you got accent i gotta ask
you straight away where you from i'm
angolan mm-hmm
what about you no no no no take a guess
i want you to gift castillo that sounds
spanish is that your real last name your
government things okay you might be
you'll definitely be caribbean
right
yeah you're good you're good you're warm
maybe like guyana or something no good
honey but i know guyana but you're good
you're close you're close where are you
from dominican and grenadian oh damn
people always ask me from dominican not
dominican republic though oh dominica
oh okay that's cool you're the first
i've met from there for real yeah yeah
yeah nice nice nice nice that's so messy
so look yeah you know what this is about
yeah you're gonna give me a ring a ring
so what like a like an onion ring thing
like no i i can't i think they got that
here you know i came for diamonds
diamonds it's either love
money or diamonds i like diamonds
mountain we're gonna go to sierra leone
for that oh i'm angolan we got some
there oh i like that i like that you see
now you already know what it's about
yeah i'm basically trying to find real
love and basically i want to find out if
the girl over here for the money and
clout
of the hair for real life what are you
looking for
i'm looking for a challenge a challenge
yeah look i'm looking for somebody to
entertain my mind you seem like you got
like some bossy aura
i'm a dangerous woman they say
what kind of danger are we talking about
i know a lot you can get a lot of men
sent away kind of thing i can do a lot
i'm a bit of a magician nothing so you
can just make them disappear one call i
know when golden women they can get you
disappearing i mean if you know your
powers as a woman
and you you know so now this leads to my
my first question i gotta ask you yeah i
do a madness yeah now the feds come
through they lock me up send me to jail
they're saying i'm facing 25.
if it's in 25 years i can't even wrap my
way out of it like some men out here
what did you do yeah it's a mad matting
somebody got rude out to muck off the
whole family he had to lick off his head
and his whole family tree the whole
family tree's gone their ghosts now oh
wow yeah so now they're telling me i'm
gonna go away
are you gonna hold it down it depends on
how you treated me before
we aren't even going out for you um did
you buy me diamonds that's why i did the
matching to get you the diamonds um did
you treat me nice
of course massage my back and my feet of
course cook for me sometimes done though
got the baby oil out you get me got the
got the redox in the bath i'll be there
for you
are you telling the truth i said for the
whole 25 yeah you're going to be have
great heads by that i think you and this
make my loyalty
i'm a sagittarius sagittar dangerous
dangerous but we're honest we're loyal
we're optimistic we're good humid we're
the sun in human form the sergeant terms
you guys are free spirit do you like to
travel you like to me yeah don't you
like to travel i love to travel there
you go you get me i went to like
birmingham the other day
okay well i used to live in coventry so
i was involved
what did you think about a birmingham
accent shout out to the birmingham
people i like accents obviously i've got
one i can't describe my name can i so
you're like oh let's go into the city
center from birmingham for that stuff
yeah i've got a family that lives there
so matic mountain you see i'm from west
london though you get me it's the
homeowner home and a man but we're sweet
as well do you not talk like a west
london person you said you're loyal yeah
so what's your longest relationship five
years five years you committed
i don't even know amanda from five years
ago i don't even know people i went to
school with for five years annie would
have been longer if he was doing right
as well what did what did he do wrong
was he doing a madness
you have to promise me love if you're in
another verse
so did he cheat
well not that i caught but yeah you know
probably you know he was moving base
like what country was he from
niger ah go you got you got you got you
that's a mention no trouble but the
caribbeans are not much better
yeah man i don't know man but where
can't you tell by your hair like the
vanity tells me the vanity like how
because i brushed my hair you might be
trouble what are you like in the
relationship what was your longest you
know i'm not gonna lie to you i used to
be on a mating so i'm trying to change
up my life yeah i mean i used to be in a
very meeting i didn't know where i was
going i was lost and then i found myself
so now i've got to move different have
you been in a relationship before yeah
i've been in long-term relationships the
thing is back then i've seen bear go so
there was many lungs
like i said some of them people i don't
even remember
i like your honesty i gotta be honest
that's what i'm saying that's what it's
about money and clout
versus love so i gotta be honest okay
cool yes so let me ask you something
yeah do you satisfy you sexually
when you know your body
is you can do anything it's magic see so
man was a dj like with a dicks like yo
well he didn't need to be a dj i dj my
own self he's fine
that's good you know your body what's
your thing then what do you like do you
know what it's not about
the action i feel like it's about
a connection
the language about the language if you
pick up on it if you've got that magic
then it's good if it's not then
because you know when you're really into
something you get that animal love you
know what i'm talking about yeah yeah
you do you want to lick their sweat you
just sense it you feel the spirit you
feel the light everything feel it you
want to lick that sweat you want to grab
them up you just grab their foot like
you want to do all of that
i mean like an animal if it feels right
don't worry about that why don't you
want to know how old i am i do because i
need to be known if you're some legal
team because you might not be able to
drink this so how old are you how old do
you think
well it better be of age because i'm
about to done off this whole thing right
now right what do you think you'll be
surprised i think most people get it
really wrong 25 oh that's cute no i'm
29. big y'all see that's come on let's
check it
out there you go what is this no i
i don't know it's semantic
don't worry it's not no bill cosby thing
like it's good it's so cool
they wouldn't change no if it's not
spiked or something i don't know never
you've been on a mad thing before
i would never wait wait hold on
don't worry about that why pressure and
pain in all digital platforms coming
real soon that's what we're going to
talk about so you're one of those ones
so you ask me my age you don't tell me
yours we're good what's your name then
your full name castello that's my
government name my last name either your
name or your age needs something well my
name castello castillo and his location
see i'm glad you told me how to
pronounce it because you know what it
means
castle castle
i learned that i learned that i learned
it's powerful yeah so you make me feel
good about myself that's what i like i
like that yeah so this one i want to ask
you so
you've come on the thing money or clout
are you looking for love i am looking
for the right love not just any love
what's the wrong love toxic love but
toxic logo feels good though it feels
good it feels good you want that brother
standing outside your house like yo
if no no no no no no no no no i want him
to be standing outside my door and i
opened the door and i said i'm like wow
babe you've got this one for me these
diamonds and for me i'm really that
beautiful to you diamond what's this
[ __ ] doing for a living with the
diamonds that's that's i don't know work
hard it's up to you what you do was he
working in canary wall for now he's got
good i mean do you know what toxic love
it is nice you know you feel first like
oh you know falling in love you're the
most amazing thing in the world until it
goes wrong um when it goes wrong that's
when it's amazing yeah that's why i want
to know what's wrong with you now what
are your traumas there's a lot you get
me and if i take these shades off this
whole room will get dark i want to see
i'm not scared so i gotta get to know
you first that's why we're here are you
scared of my eyes pressure and pain on
all digital platforms
you're working hard you're working hard
promoting yourself like cool of course
of course so let me know so what do you
do like you look like you've got a big
boy job you look like you do serious
things well i like to think i do
i'm a business operations lead
yeah
that's that's the real thing
you have to apply for that that's good
you want to hit the next bit
for community empowerment organization
so i work to empower and educate our
community the black the youth i don't
know and emerging creatives i like that
because there's a lot of men in my head
moving mad but you've got to get a man
off the streets the killing people
whether it's men just help help us all
grow and get to success let everybody be
like you don't know don't know we might
do business if we don't fall in love big
man thinks i like that i see if you're
thinking ahead you're freaking out
sounds like you want some money though i
don't feel like you want love down i'm
just i don't want money do you know what
the funniest thing is everybody has
always asked me what do you want you
want money you want to be successful no
i want the power of influence that's the
only way you can make a change and power
of enforcement is you don't actually
need money because your word is enough
to get what you want damn you see that's
that that's that good talk that you do i
like that you see that's how you get
them that's how you get their business
so why should i pick you what separates
you from all the other girls what do you
bring to the table i think you can tell
already i think that the combination of
who i am as a person is extremely unique
i have a strong history behind me from
angola for my family i love that i'm a
beautiful mix i'm extremely intelligent
if i may say so
i've got three degrees um i work hard
i'm very loyal i'm a ride-or-die type of
girl i'm smart but i'm also street smart
i'm a solution provider for most things
and i know how to love so what's your
thoughts on sex on a first date then i
don't think it's a good thing why not
though because when you engage in you
know sexual activities with somebody you
exchange energy and you need to check
people's energy first before you kind of
open that portal up i'm going to toast
you to that yeah tell you why because
i've been with some crazy girl brother
and i'm like why did i do that right why
did i stick my willy in there but i've
known my whole life's in disarray now
leave me alone come to my house at mad
times
literally i will get an injunction on
you by this do you need that in your
life no cut the headache from the
beginning by just holding on a little
bit longer test the energy test the
water today ask the questions and then
take the step what's bad sex how long do
you give a guy before you like now your
willy's dead breath is the kind i can't
deal with that you know
i feel like i can tell
by you know speaking to people what the
personality is like if it's going to be
good or not um so shout out to the small
willie man out there bro if you want to
live in a hard life give me go get go
get a dbo breath go go to go to colombia
brother get a dbo extend your [ __ ] rev
big man do me to tell you what i think
about you so far i need you to go on i
need you to tell me i think that
you've got
moves i think you could be good but i
think you might be a bit overconfident
so you might have to be said like hold
on babe not that not there yet no no no
slow slow slow no not that whole this
one oh please wait wait wait that's too
hard chill chill too we love caution oh
sleep
massive is mad yeah so well i can tell
that's always a good sign though that
you know that right now of course but at
the same time like you've got to test
out the waters you've got to let it
marinate like i can't just be running in
there and just try to tear it up but
that's a madness i go oh i've got to
take time you've got to explore the girl
in his body get me like the nipple
touching like nipple just just a bit of
that you'll be able to know it's not
like
it's like uh of course
some man they don't do that again again
no four players like yo come on babies
let's do this i can't do that yeah no
that's a bit much you gotta take it easy
you gotta get to know the person first
you know and then let me ask you
something like i'm a freaky guy you get
me i'm a freaky guy like i like i like
my gal to be freaky to get me like i
like i like the sloppy head not the head
when it's sloppy i like that [ __ ] i like
saliva and dribble everywhere i like
that matching yeah cool why are you like
you're a freaky person or you're like
are you in the bed and then you're
planking like what's going on with that
what do you think do you want me to be
honest with you
i think you want a matching i think i
think
what made you say that nah i could tell
i feel i feel like i feel like i feel
like you can change a man's life yeah
that's why i say i know
i feel like they run you down you can
tell already why you should be picking
me over other people i don't need to say
much i could tell i could tell that
literally men would go mad over that
900. 100
rounds second second and thirds i think
so fifth six seven six seven
give me a ring straight away as i said i
came for my ring so the number is so
good they want to give you a ring
afterwards
it's easy to fall in love with me but
it's hard to handle me when you say hard
to handle you what does that mean i
think i'm a challenging woman in the
sense that i step on an ego's
like sensitivity a lot so if you're a
sensitive man with a sensitive ego
you really need to check yourself so you
tell a man you tell a man like yo you're
really smooth don't be chatting [ __ ]
wrap lower the bass in your voice when
you chat to me if that's more witty
no no no if you annoy me i go a bit
formal and therefore i patronize you and
kind of make you feel a little bit dumb
and i think that's not good you know
guys tend to have sensitive you can get
a man's head and then just mash him up
yeah
that's why i said i'm a dangerous woman
so you said you're dangerous so what's
the craziest thing you've ever done
until x to get revenge i don't do
revenge you don't do revenge no you know
like the energy you put into the world
is always reciprocated so if you put bad
energy it's going to come back to you so
when they do something bad to me i know
i forgot them at some point see that's
why we're different like i'm a bit of a
petty person what did you do i'm a
better petty person now literally try
and find out what happened to your life
see if you fell off if you became a
knitty i want to see that i want to ride
past and be like yo look at you idiot
isn't that a headache though it is so
you gotta let that go but i'm like yeah
yeah
see i like that i like that see that's
the whole point you've got to grow and
build and learn of course have you been
with any celebrities
you dated any rappers
yeah
that was my experience but he was wasn't
a celebrity
he was a rapper he was a very talented
person when you say so when you say he
wasn't a celebrity was like he was
popular he's just going to studio just
making things that nobody'll ever hear
in her life no you'd hear them he's good
but what's his best song so he's got
this song with um what's his name young
saber
and some other guy what's his name hachi
or something it's quite nice pigmenting
shattering pressure and painting on all
digital platforms
you know what do you know what but you
know i don't mind
dating whoever i date i actually through
him i learned to do sound engineering
so he taught you something that's
important taught me a lot five years is
a long time told me a lot about the road
tell me a lot about music tell me about
the road
[Music]
no it wasn't that deep but it's just
more about like tactics and strategies
to survive in the streets of london i
learned that a lot from him people's
bank details and things like that
next thing you're in the modes that's
why you're smiling right now i just told
you i know a lot of things about a lot
of things
would you ever date a man that's broke
yeah i mean like the thing is what do
you mean by broke like he has no money
i'm talking about like i can't make the
ends meet the ends ain't meeting the
ends are like way over here and they
don't want to meet well if i love him
the first thing i'll do is say babes why
are the ends not meeting what's wrong
how are you feeling that's always the
solution if he says i'm focusing on my
music career and things just ain't
popping what's your plan to get to the
popping part he says i need to hold her
at stormzy and do a tune with him do you
have the money to do so nah babes he
says i need some of your money can you
give it to me so i can get to that can
we find another alternative before we
get to storms because it's quite big you
need to have steps in between create a
plan so you've got to do a track with
wavy stab man some random nobody knows
him it's okay because then you can
promote it there's ways to promote i
know people that can you know
i told you i'm resourceful
so being broke doesn't always mean that
it's a bad thing it depends on your
situation i'm understanding so when you
say a result are you known in these
streets because the streets they do talk
you know the streets they just send me
messages from the streets just talk
there's the streets is your name clean
out here in these streets yeah i feel
like a lot of people would have probably
seen my face they don't know my name but
they will know from now
like that's power right there you get me
i like that you've got control you know
what you're doing yeah i'm trying to say
that's a beautiful thing i don't want
money i want power that's a beautiful
thing so let me ask you this what's the
freakiest thing you've ever done
this is the first date what kind of
question is that um see that's that's
good
didn't fall for the trap she just i like
a lot of risky things like i want to go
do things in public get me i want to do
all these things it sounds exciting so
you like that excitement yeah i like
exciting i like to think outside the box
experiment
experimenting is good not in too mad
though no but you got to be open-minded
what's your definition of open-minded
though it's like
if it somewhat makes sense why not try
it don't knock it till you try you know
i mean what if he's not your babes i
want you to peg me oh no i think that's
a bit actually
in it that's a bit extra that that kind
of reveals other parts of you that i
probably won't like because why do you
need that to be done but there's other
alternatives some men like from freaky
things so if you really loved the guy he
said yo babes i got you this [ __ ] suit
with a strap on thing like you've got go
ham on me no
i mean maybe for only fans if he's going
to give us a lot of cash
would you ever do anything
i think so
literally because when the money starts
dropping people won't be judging and
saying oh she's on only fans they'll be
enjoying with you at the table popping
champagne see i've always wanted to do
only fans i like only fans because i
feel like i've got it you haven't done
it i thought you lived on it right now
you seem like you're not as freaky as
you say no i'm trying to be the
president you get me i'm trying to have
a i'm trying to be like boris johnson
back you get me so what are you doing
for that since obviously i work in
community empowerment
so we can we can empower to give them
yeah before i can't work for the feds
though like no no no no no
i'm african we can't do that
we like to
work outside the world sometimes
i don't see
that's dope that's dope
what do you like most about me like
what's your impressions like what's my
what's my best feature you got good skin
that means you're probably drink plenty
of water you drink a lot
good hair strong thick thank you so much
man they don't they don't drink water
that's why their face is looking like a
snickers bar no well raise them they
think it's moist to take care of
themselves it's not it's health now big
man sing shout out to nivea breath cream
your skin how old are you then i need to
know because obviously you're skinny you
don't have like
pressure and pain on all digital
products
let's say some famous rapper comes
around yeah he's super famous he's got
mine he's got the eye outside yeah
you've got the jewels shining glistening
got a track suit and not looking all
good and let's say for me i'm bummy like
literally my box is automatic i just
turned that [ __ ] inside out my life is
nice cool now literally right now we're
so broke i'm doing like a little picnic
date right now yeah so then let's say
we're chilling about to catch the bus
having a little oysters in that man
comes up pulls up with a nice r8 he's
like yo babe you're looking chris
are you staying with me are you going
with him
at the risk of sounding really rude
i feel like
only women that are not used to
attention will react in a way where they
have to chase him to use to people
saying hey you're beautiful it's nothing
it has to be a mental connection
this
the looks everything is too shallow i
know what i look like i like that so you
need to connect with my mind i like that
so what do you think about gear that go
to the buy and all that like that they
get flown out have you ever been flown
out no
i travel on my own
you've got your own money
i mean each to their own you do what you
want use your power as a woman to enjoy
why not but for me i don't know my mum
taught me different she's very
independent and you know very strong
with five women in the house so
i love that i love that so let's say
went up to your parents john what would
their first impressions be of me oh
okay so first of all the gold teeth my
mom would be like dee come on what are
you doing you sure
then the tattoo sounds like looks
dangerous
but i think they would appreciate the
fact that your caribbean i think the
spanish name would kind of give a bit of
edge because portuguese and england were
very kind of connected with like
caribbean and latin culture so give me
some favor and win me some favor of my
last name yeah yeah yeah if you don't
say above not be nice i don't say brave
it's mad if you like soften up a little
bit you should be okay i like that i
like see i like your way of thinking
yeah so you're not a materialistic
person you're not all of that like you
know but then you want the diamonds
what's that saying i'm not materialistic
in general but i like diamonds in
mongolia and you see my blood
my dad used to deal with diamonds alone
when we were younger so i forgot
fascination so that's what you're used
to that's what i'm used to so if a guy
can't buy you diamonds this can't work
it can work
i don't know i feel like i'm going to be
successful so i don't really need to
rely on my man to you know bring too
much cash as long as he brings the hard
work so you're a generous person so do
you give the man anything like what
about me like i'm stupid generous i wish
i wasn't i'm a sucker tell me more about
that
literally what is mine is yours what is
yours is yours someone's used mine yeah
you well not yet it depends i mean you
have to impress me isn't it said i'm
like oh base like i'm learning like i'm
low on cash i give me a little 50 pound
now it's so easy i don't know why people
don't do that more often see i like that
i see your honest person i like yeah
when is your birthday july i'm a council
oh you guys are meant to be successful
most successful zodiac yeah
yeah yeah i like that you're teaching me
things about me
what's the conversation for in it if you
want to on a date with a guy and he
didn't pay on the first date would that
bother you
if you invited me you pay for sure
michael i mean of course course
invitation
but if we both decide to go together
i'll normally i would um offer to split
i think it's polite let me ask you this
what's your type of guy like i know it's
me obviously but i'm saying in general
uh six foot tall minimum yeah six foot
tall minimum okay cool question that
means i can go to little winning get a
lithuanian leg lift and get six eight
soon
ideally this is the thing right i've
spoken to my friends about it and you
know like my dad strong black man and
you know he's the first person that i
fell in love with as a man you know like
that idea so i'm looking for a big
strong
african man however
i'm also very realistic i know that
african men are trouble they have a lot
of trauma they haven't dealt with that's
ideally like i would like to have
a strong black man that is emotionally
mature
and willing to work on these traumas and
grow from within
that's like free men rev that's smart
you just i
it's too much for you it's not like he
wants the donors the pesos it sounds
like you want the monies man i want
everything you want everything i'm close
to everything as a woman i believe look
right i like to look good i like nice
things i like designer i like to travel
i like all the amazing stuff in the
world right i do but that doesn't stop
me from loving somebody the right way as
i did i'm generous give everything oh
i'm so honest and truthful no matter
what you do to me i will not cheat i
will not talk to someone else i'll just
be like why babe why and so you've never
cheated ever in your life you went to
god that's right 29 years and no matter
what you did to me i don't i'd rather
break up first and then so a man's never
cheated on you before you know what i
need to give that to your best friend
you know he gotta have that for like two
minutes let me just let me just let him
wear it out past the ball i swear i've
been cheated on
but i i've never caught it so i don't
really care do you never been in a
relationship looked at your man and just
thought like right like you look kind of
dusty but you look a bit crusty today
i've got good taste
i don't get myself into those situations
without
you know being pleased visually so are
you a looks or you're a money person
what do you want is it which is more
important why don't you keep talking
about money you seem to be the sort of
person that likes money or maybe you're
traumatized i've been done before and i
know what's it's like having no money so
i know you need it
yeah i mean and i know what it's like to
have to make that 10 pound loss but for
a month yeah you got now you got jacob's
crackers rev
as a woman that doesn't rely on men i
have to do a lot for myself so i know
what it feels like to stretch i've
studied so i've been a student i know it
feels like to stretch i'm the daughter
of a single mother immigrant i know what
it feels like to stretch so you've got
to drink that tap navy on you've got to
drink that technology no no never tap
never never but when when you ain't got
it the tap becomes that's champagne no
no no no no you prioritize you say
things you know as a woman this is the
thing a good woman will always have a
reserve for the priorities which will be
food
and
a roof my mom taught me that so you ever
been broke before
oh yeah of course how broken what kind
of book we're talking about i've not
been able to buy clothes for over a year
you know where you're hustling you're
grinding so what kind of clothes though
like when you took my designer clothes
no like just clothes where you actually
have to go absolutely
zero to be able to make it to the other
side the sacrifices that you make and
it's no big deal it's like going for a
run i like that you see i like that that
means you've been through the trenches i
like a woman that's been for the
trenches why do you think i talk like
this
so you've been through the trenches
you've seen some hardships oh yeah
so i've had a great date with you we'll
talk i've had an amazing date with you
you're great yeah how's it been for you
yeah it's been good it's been
interesting i thought you're going to be
more challenging though
i'm
you look more rough on tv actually like
in terms of how you present yourself now
the main event is a nice you've got some
sorryness to you you're kind of smooth
and like yeah i like that
i say we're taking a leap of faith right
now yeah and i put down 1 000. you know
1 000 gb people have pounds bro with a
queen's face on it
yeah
would you choose the money
or would you choose pursuing love would
you pursue love or choose
the dhanas
well from what you've can tell from how
we've spoken do you really think i'd be
choosing the money if i have a good
chance at love
a thousand pounds it's not that much i
like that you can make that yeah so
let's just choose a beautiful day
i'm beautiful
okay
[Music]
keep your hands up of the way
don't worry don't worry there you go
nice to meet you nice to meet you again
have a safe journey thank you
big man sing it but it was mad cause in
the face but
i'm talking about them i have to sort
that out because
i'm gonna have to sort that out
wow i'm good you're like one two glass
of water my god oh sorry can i drink it
i'm scared
can she drink that rev don't be moving
mad you lot getting
the vibe i'm getting right now is you
like black guys i'm not gonna lie
you